quimper c'est d'abord la cathédrale
placé sous l'invocation de saint
corentin breton de bonne grâce
elle est visible de partout d'où que
vous veniez elle vous fait signe elle
nous attire au creux des plus douces
collines de cornouaille et pourtant le
berceau de la ville son église mère
c'est un rude édifice roman dans le
faubourg de locmaria mais voilà entre
les flèches boutiques qui ont un peu
plus de 100 ans et présente déjà la même
patte inc et les fondements millénaire
s'érige un cavalier de granit c'est le
roi de la ville d'ys graal ont le grand
celui qui avait sa capitale à quimper
et maintenant le regard fixé sur l'ouest
sur les campagnes et sur la mer au loin
il attend patiemment que l'océan lui
rende la ville engloutie
nous attendons avec lui
à quimper la marée monte deux fois par
jour pour rejoindre la rivière aude est
aussi d'un autre cours d'eau le ster
l'endroit de la triple rencontre a donné
son nom à la ville puisque le mot breton
quimper signifie confluent et sur le lit
de l'aude est des passerelles de fer
relie les marronniers de la rive droite
haute amelia de la rive gauche
la vieille ville anciennement clause
près celle de vieux logis
telle cette maison des cariatides où
l'on conspiraient sous la ligue pour
l'un ou l'autre parti ait des rues
traverse des venelles étroites aux noms
pittoresques
quimper porte eurolacq reddition
populaire exactement 33 cm de dentelle
pour la coiffe bigoudène
et il y à gros à parier que c'est ici
que l'on verra frissonner sous le ciel
les derniers grands pavois
les derniers grands habillement de tête
qui furent la gloire de notre
civilisation paysanne
mais quimper à des illustrations plus
bourgeoise plus officiel ici naquit jean
elie fréron le redoutable polémiste qui
teinte en échec olterre lui même rené
madec qui devint nabab aux indes en
marchant sur les traces de duplex
étudiants à quimper
laennec le docteur admirable inventeur
de l'auscultation médiate les matchs
jacob le poète qui découvrit dans sa
tête des royaumes pathétique c'est
farfelu dont la capitale était toujours
quimper même à paris et qu'un père est
aussi le siège d'un très bel artisanat
celui de la terre vivante que l'on ne
cesse de modeler depuis des siècles pour
l'utilité
et de peindre pour le plaisir
de peindre sur des références populaires
que l'on retrouvera symbolisé dans des
bijoux d'or et d'argent
et quimper est encore une ville où l'on
parle breton que la cornouaille
bretonnante à siège de toutes parts ici
flambe dans les coeurs et gronde sous
l'os des crânes les fidélité historique
et les passions sans cesse renouvelée
par les problèmes du jour enfin à
quimper bon souffle ne serait mentir
et il n'est pas besoin du nombre des
années pour s'emparer du le bombarde
celle qui entraînera peut-être pendant
les fêtes de cornouaille
les milliers de danseurs du fest-noz de
la fête de nuit ou éclater une joie
irrésistible venu du fond des siècles
breton